et
bonjour bienvenue dans votre émission
montre moi un signe ça va
tous les jours des entendants et des
sources croisent et ne communique pas
je vais vous montrer les signes pour
rétablir la communication et l'améliorer
puis vous avez leur à vous voulez savoir
leur valeur alors il est 15h30 alors il
est plus
15h10 pain 30
15h30
les entendants 10 15h30 pour les minutes
c'est lourd
c'est extrêmement simple même facile par
exemple deux heures trois heures 5
heures 7h15
- le cas la demie
le matin
mais vous
l'après midi
le soir
minuit
qu'est ce qu'un set
d'accord je regarde 3h03 comme ça qu'on
fait 3h d'accord 3h30 et demi d'accord
et demi après midi de l'après midi trois
heures et demie de l'après midi car
quand j'ai conclu c'est bien tu as
compris
bonjour l heure est il
et qu'à moins le cas
la demie matin midi
après midi soir
minuit au revoir bonjour excusez moi
mais par omar bongo
vous êtes sourde d'accord vous lisez sur
les lèvres doucement je cherche la
mairie la mairie
oui la mairie
à droite
tous droits
et après
difficile de lui expliquer peut-être que
j'ai signé un peu trop vite le signe
pour aller à droite le signe pour aller
tout droit le signe pour aller à gauche
je vais essayer de lui expliquer plus
lentement pour voir si elle comprend à
droite
d'accord
tous droits
le rond point d'accord à gauche
d'accord et je vois
oh
la pharmacie
la pharma 10 est d'accord à côté la
mairie d'accord merci
oh
bonjour montre moi un signe direction à
droite tout droit
à gauche
rond-point pharmacie
mais lee
permis de conduire au revoir